welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on information retrieval
we're going to briefly review classical
IR approaches it will be a brief
overview because our focus in this
course is on neural information
retrieval but I did want to cover these
classical ideas because they're very
powerful and classical IR systems could
very well be important components in
models that you develop
the standard starting point for
classical IR is the term document Matrix
I've got a fragment of a real term
document Matrix on the slide here the
terms are along the rows the documents
go along the columns and the cells
record the number of times that each
word appeared in each one of these
documents these are standardly very
large very sparse matrices but they
encode latently a lot of information
about which documents are relevant to
which query terms
TF IDF approach tfidf is a common
approach to massaging those term
document values to get more information
about relevance from The Matrix here's
how TF IDF works we begin from a corpus
of documents d
term frequency is actually internal to
each one of these documents TF of a word
give it a document is simply the number
of times that that word appears in the
document divided by the total length of
the document so a standard relative
frequency value
document frequency is a function of
words and our entire Corpus and we're
simply counting the number of documents
that contain the target word regardless
of how frequent the word is in each one
of those documents simple occurrence the
number of documents that contains the
target word
and then inverse document frequency is
just the log of the total size of our
Corpus divided by the document frequency
value that we calculated
and then TF IDF is simply the product of
the TF and the IDF values
here's a little worked example I have a
term document Matrix on the slide in the
left here we calculate the IDF values
those are given on the right and then
the term frequency values are given at
the bottom of the slide and then we get
the product of those for the TF IDF
values down in the lower right here and
I think you can start to see some
noteworthy patterns for example the term
C is in relatively few documents just
two of them and it's relatively frequent
in both of those documents and as a
result it has high TF IDF values we
could also look at term D here it occurs
in only one document and is relatively
infrequent in that document as a result
of occurring in only one document it
ends up with a pretty high TF IDF value
because its IDF value is so high even
though its term frequency is low and
correspondingly
dot uh word a term a here gets a TF IDF
value of zero it was highly frequent in
document 4 but it occurs in all of the
documents and therefore ends up with an
IDF value of zero and therefore TF IDF
value of zero so it gives you a sense
for how these values combine to give us
TF IDF let's actually break down the
scoring in a little bit more of a
systematic way starting with the IDF
values
for IDF we do have a little bit of a
problem if we have a word that occurs in
no documents then the TF uh then the IDF
value is undefined because we need to
divide by zero so what I've done here is
simply stipulate that that's a zero
if a word appears in just one document
it gets a maximal IDF value
and the IDF values drop off steadily as
the word appears and more and more
documents all the way up to appearing in
every document given the little Corpus
of 10 documents that we're imagining and
that too is an IDF value of zero as we
saw on the previous slide and the idea
here is that by the time you have a word
that appears in every document it's
simply not informative about which
documents are relevant and so its IDF
value should be minimized
and here's a slide showing selected TF
IDF values and I think the pattern is
very clear TF IDF reaches its maximal
values for terms that occur very
frequently in very few documents and
correspondingly tfidf values are at
their lowest for words that are very
infrequent in very many documents those
are the tiny bubbles up here that's the
kind of core behavior of TF IDF what
we're really looking for is words that
are truly distinguishing indicators of
particular documents
to calculate relevant scores for a given
query which might contain multiple terms
the standard approach is simply to sum
over whatever weighting we're using for
the term document Matrix so for example
if weight here is TF IDF we simply sum
over the TF IDF values for every word in
our query and that gives us a relevant
score for the entire user query
bm25 is arguably the most famous
classical IR approach bm25 stands for
best match attempt 25 which suggests a
lot of exploration of the different
hyper parameters of this model looking
for a solution that was best and this
has indeed turned out to be an
enduringly good solution
with bm25 you're going to see that this
is a kind of enhanced version of TF IDF
We Begin from smoothed IDF values these
are essentially the IDF values that I
just showed you with a little bit of an
adjustment to handle the undefined in
this case that we briefly worried about
the next component is scoring and this
is kind of analogous to term frequency
and you can see in this definition that
term frequency is an important component
we also have two hyper parameters K and
B which I'm going to talk about in a
second
but just to round this out the bm25
weight is a combination of those
adjusted IDF values and the scoring
values which are now are analogous
somewhat to term frequency and TF IDF
so the definitions are different and
we're going to dive into them but at a
high level you can see it's a product of
two very similar values to each to the
ones we had for TF IDF
let's take a look at the individual
components in a bit more detail starting
with IDF what I have on the slide here
is the IDF plot that I showed you
previously from the TF IDF definitions
and then I have the bm25 variant of that
at the bottom here and what I've done is
just emphasize that this s value here is
standardly set at 0.5 but we could in
principle adjust it
so here are a few values for that value
s the standard value is the one in
purple that's 0.5 and you can see that
the result is that we very closely match
the standard IDF values throughout the
entire space of document frequency
values with the exception that we give a
very high value incidentally to words
that appear in no documents that won't
turn out to be relevant and what really
happens as we adjust s is we're
adjusting things at that kind of really
degenerate part of this overall space
for words that appear in no documents
once we get into words appearing in
documents the values track pretty
closely with maybe the exception that if
you set s very high you get real
differences in the lowest part of this
spectrum
but by and large if we set it at 0.5
we're just reproducing the IDF values
that we had from the earlier definitions
the scoring function is more nuanced as
a result of having lots of hyper
parameters so let's break this down a
little bit see if we can get some
analytic insights installed into what's
happening
the scoring function is repeated at the
bottom here and I've highlighted an
orange a term that plays the role of
penalizing long documents and then this
plot should help us see precisely how
that plays out so let's imagine that
we're looking at a document that has
length 10. I have the term frequency
values along the x-axis and the bm25
scoring values along the y-axis
if I am looking at a document that has
uh average if sorry if the Corpus has
average document length of 10 that's the
purple line here and that's the same
length as our example document
as our example document becomes long
relative to the average length with 5
and 3 you can see that the scoring
values systematically go down
so to summarize as our Target document
is long relative to the average the
scores are diminished the overall effect
of this as I said is to penalize long
documents and the intuition there is
that long documents might just as a
result of being long contain more terms
and therefore on average we should trust
the terms they do contain less as
evidence for our overall relevance
scoring
so that's the penalty for long documents
now let's dive into the role of B the
function of that hyper parameter B is to
control the amount of the penalty that
we give to Long documents so let's break
that down a little bit over here again
we have a Target document of length 10
that's our example and we have an
average document length of 5 over here
and you can see that as we increase B
from 0.1 to 1 the overall effect is to
diminish the scores so higher values of
b mean more of a penalty given to Long
documents because that reduces the score
even more
over on the right here if our Target
document is the example document has
length 10 which is the same as the
average document length for our Corpus
then the value of B makes no difference
as a result of the fact that there's no
penalty even to apply in these cases
it's really just for long documents
relative to the average that b is
controlling the amount of penalty that
we apply in those cases
and then what about K what is the effect
of K it appears here in the scoring
function the overall effect is to
flatten out higher frequencies and I
think one way to get a grip on this is
to think about the extreme situation in
which you have set K very very low this
would be a non-standard value for k
in the situation where you set it very
low what you essentially do is turn the
scoring function into an indicator
function you can see that we get a
register of a scoring value if the word
is in the document and then it simply
flattens out over all the different
values for term frequency so it's like
you appeared and then I don't care how
many times you appeared I'm hardly going
to adjust the scoring
and then as you make K larger you get
less and less of a dramatic effect like
that and so you you care more and more
about whether the word appears
frequently in the documents or not so
this red line is really an extreme case
where you've decided not to care very
much about the different values of
relative frequency a more standard value
for K is 1.2 and that's giving this kind
of modest diminishing amount as you get
terms that are really frequent in
documents you kind of flatten out the
scoring function
so that's the overall effect flattening
out higher frequencies with the value of
K controlling how much flattening you
decide to do
with those components in place we can
return to our classic inverted index
from information retrieval that's an
inverted index in the sense that we go
from terms to documents rather than
documents to terms have our query come
in we do our term lookup and previously
I showed you this as simply a list of
documents but now of course with
something like bm25 or TF IDF we can
augment this with pre-computed scores or
document frequency values and with
pre-computed IDF values and so we have
all the ingredients we need for a given
query to do full-on document scoring
very efficiently and that is one
essential ingredient for why these
classical approaches are so massively
scalable
that's kind of it for what I wanted to
cover on classical IR but I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention a few obvious topics
that are explored in detail in this
literature we could of course do query
and document expansion we could augment
what the user gives us and what's in our
corpus with additional information and
maybe metadata that it would help us
with relevant scoring
we could move to phrase level search I
focused on unigrams but of course that's
not a necessary restriction we could
think about engrams an even more
sophisticated Notions of linguistic
units
we haven't talked at all about term
dependence we've kind of assumed that
all the terms in a document are
independent of each other but if you
think about bigrams like New York that's
obviously an unhappy approximation we
should be thinking about how the how all
these terms have their own internal
statistical dependencies and bring that
into the search functionality
we could also this is really important
think about different document Fields
documents are not homogeneous and words
that appear in the title might have a
different relevance value inherently
than words that appear in the body of a
document and we would want our best
classical search Technologies and our
best search Technologies in general to
be sensitive to those distinctions
and then of course a big gap in what
I've showed so far is link analysis we
could think about how the documents in
our Corpus inform form an implicit graph
based on how they hyperlink with each
other and we know from Modern search
that that is a crucial factor in shaping
relevance and having the best documents
come to the top I have left that out but
it's obviously incredibly important
and then of course finally
learning to rank that is learn
functionality for what's relevant given
queries is an important feature of the
neural IR models that we've that we that
we're going to discuss I have not
introduced that in the class in the
context of classical IR but we could
have learned ranking functions that
would go beyond the simple appriory
calculations of things like TF IDF and
bm25
finally there are lots of tools out
there that would help you with classical
IR elasticsearch is widely deployed very
robust mature search technology highly
scalable lots of features pi sereni and
Prime QA are research repositories that
could also be really useful to you if
you want to think about setting up
classical IR models as baselines or as
using them in components in larger
systems that might have a small role
for neural IR models as kind of
re-rankers of results that come from a
very fast very robust classical IR
system that's a common mode to operate
in that gives you highly scalable
Solutions where the neural models that
we'll talk about later play the role of
kind of refining the core results
returned by the classical model